Liz Lemon less than a week to go before  the Iowa caucus and the latest polls  show that I'm I'm sorry sir what are you  doing it's really creepy  the way you're staring at me what is it  what's going on are you accusing me of  something is this something I did here  on the show is this something I did in  public something I did recently this  past weekend something I did in public  this past but wait I know what it might  be I'm so sorry  that's my call you hooked on I just made  the final payment I apologize  let me get my insurance information  I'll be driving it [ __ ]  [Applause]  you know you're right I was out of line  and I just I kind of lost control I'm  sorry I'm not the one to whom you need  to confess responsibility  [Music]  [Music]  I'm glad you went for that hey thanks  for watching please subscribe to my  youtube channel so they will stop making  me shoot these videos please